How does one save a marriage when it seems that there is no longer attraction
both physically and intellectually?
There are kids involved,
which is the main reason for wanting to save the marriage.
Huh?
Well,
all right.
I know a couple of things about that.
I mean,
the first thing I would say is that if you haven't had any intimate interaction
with one another for quite a long period of time,
that can put both people into a stagnant state where desire starts to slip away.
What,
what sex therapists recommend under such conditions is to while essentially
start in some way,
start dating again.
So you could ask your partner to go out to a movie or something like that.
And you know,
maybe when you come home you could,
you could neck for a little while.
Like teenagers,
that's probably a word that no one uses anymore,
but kind of pull back and you got to agree,
say not to,
um,
engage in full sexual activity for a while,
but to tease each other and to play a bit.
Even if you're not attracted,
you have to act,
act it out for awhile and hopefully you can get the motor running again.
The other thing I would say is that you guys might want to sit down and make a
joint plan.
It's like what?
Cause I,
a marriage is like a story that two people are acting out simultaneously and you
have to have shared goals and because you're both rowing the same boat,
let's say,
and if you don't have a destination in mind,
then,
well maybe you're rowing in circles or maybe you're just standing still.
So I would say work hard to put some romance back in the relationship.
You know,
you could say to each other,
look,
let's try this for six months and just see how it goes.
We'll have two dates a week for the first month.
We won't have any sex,
but we'll play around and then,
you know,
we'll see how that goes and,
and,
but we'll try it out for the,
for,
for the whole,
for the whole six months.
Um,
there are reasons to save a marriage.
I mean,
it's hard on kids.
Divorce is really hard on kids and it's hard on the adults involved too.
Um,
so,
uh,
I would say
you have to negotiate an agreement and you,
you know,
you could try the future authoring program,
both of you.
What I would recommend for example,
is that you each do the future authoring program separately.
So that's that self authoring.com cause then you both have a life plan and then
you could sit down and read each other's future authoring plans and see if you
have some things in common and then see if you can figure out how to support
each other with regards to each of you obtaining what you want.